gut ich begrüße ganz pünktlich um 12 uhr
15 genauer gesagt 12 16
zum heutigen seminar uns hat natürlich
zur direkt übertragen
das zu hause an den bildschirmen tempels
konzert immer sagen sie können
mitdiskutieren
wir setzen heute etwas voraus wie beim
letzten sitzung leider nur kurz anreisen
konnten wir die letzten sitzung und sehr
wehgetan gemacht hatten
über diese klassifikation 20 diese
verschiedenen formen des unmoralischen
es ist mir persönlich kochen anliegen
weil ich glaube dass hier lesen
forschungsbedarf besteht wie man
ordnungen diese verschiedenen formen des
unmoralischen bekommt und wir fangen mit
dem ersten euro spannung nämlich ein
also selbstanzeige nur 21 minuten zuvor
gekommen als und das ist also praktisch
unser thema und ich möchte jetzt obwohl
ich heute ganz mit sicherheit darauf
dass mobbing
ihnen kommen würde und auch auf alle
anderen dinge möchte ich jetzt doch noch
mal vor belegungen machen nämlich auch
was ihren möglichen hausarbeiten trifft
für die sich jetzt zu langsam
anmelden können wenn sie wollen und zwar
können wir uns fragen wie können wir
wissenschaftlich
und philosophische zu hause über das
schweigen
ich hatte schon mal eine ähnliche frage
aufgeworfen wie manchmal sinnvoller
dieses unmoralische sprechen kann weil
man doch sagen könnte am besten man
schweigt es tote oder machen renoviert
ist oder es ist dunkel man kann dann
über ghana zahlen und das ist unsere
herausforderung wie können wir dieses
fällt diese phänomene durchdringen und
zwar im griff
wir müssen das problem entwickeln das
prinzip wie kevin oder sogar zu
begreifen
nur so könnten eurovision schreiben und
jetzt habe ich so ein paar angebote für
kategorien können
sollten wir mal eine täterin und
perspektive einnehmen und eine
opferperspektive in jedem fall in jeder
form des romans täterperspektive
bedeutet und handlungen verhalten
einstimmung motive wir haben das
eigentlich erwartet
wer das letzte mal entwickelt die möchte
ich heute auch noch mal kurz angewandt
werden dass unsere meniskus und opfer
perspektive bedeutet meter esse des
opfers wird verletzt und niemand
investiert sich die verletzlichkeit
hatte diese zwei perspektive zu rücken
wenn immer auf jede form des
unmoralischen werfen weil eben das
originalstück der regel immer etwas ist
was zwischen zwei oder mehreren personen
entstanden gehen es kann auch im
einzelfall im selben fall nur sich dabei
um eine person handel nahm sie mit
wo ist eine form aus anorganischen gibt
die nur mit einer weise
beim night richtig das ist sicherlich
eine sache die wir gesehen haben nicht
sich zeigen muss nach außen hin und die
auch die personen der etwas geneidet
wird gar nicht mitbekommen muss zu dass
sie gar nicht drunter leidet und jetzt
überlegen sie mal jeder für sich denn
sie wüssten jemand ist neidisch auf sie
wegen einer sache von der selbst
vielleicht nicht mehr wussten dass um
derentwillen wie man auf so neidisch
sein könnte wie würden sie sich fühlen
bedroht würden sie sich nicht auch ein
bisschen geschmeichelt fühlen sich schon
wenn mir jetzt da jemand zum beispiel
erzählt also gehört werden musste
gestehen ich situation zusammen zu
werden ich war lange zeit weiter
dieses würde ich mich auch ein bisschen
geschmeichelt wenn es jemand zugeben
würde das heißt jemand der bezug geben
dass allein durch bis er ist ja gar
nicht mehr nötig versteht sich dass das
läuft der letzte sein
jemand der sagt ich bin neidisch auf sie
den winter gehen würden sie nicht
unbedingt mehr als froh war als als
jemand anziehen wäre da eine formation
moralischen hängen weil wir die
teilnehmer ein teilnehmer den von uns
jetzt mal sehr treffend gesagt der
neidische eben gerade sein
nicht zunehmen wird weil das ich
vielleicht auch schäden oder weil er
sich jedenfalls darauf was vormachen das
wird das nie zugeben
und wenn das dazu gibt dann würden wir
das als einen sympathischen zugang
ziehen oder als überlegen was ich also
wenn ich für mich denkt da bin ich nein
ich das sagen wir auch mein personal tag
dann ist es einige komplimente sagt
achter wenn ich nein ich das kurz
dahinter auf diesen schönen urlaub immer
das erfinden als ein sympathischer
niemand zugibt dass in einem spiel ist
das heißt denen uns denn ein betrifft
bekommen wir es nicht mit man könnte
vielleicht ist so mitbekommt dass jemand
drittes und diese person das glaub ich
leidenschaftlich und dann höre diese
person für uns auf uns konzentrieren
aber wenn es jemand direkt und sagt ich
bin nicht schuldig nehmt es diese person
in dem es zu gestehen
die unmoralischen charakter würde dich
sondern es geht hier also eine
moralische gedanken über nämlich
anerkennung dabei in dem die person
ich bin markt sagt bin nicht auf dich
deswegen um etwas
als die person anerkennt dass ich diesen
wert oder was auch immer haben
das ist eine form von anerkennung von
ernsten hat nicht von missachtung
sollten beachtung und der leiter ist
praktisch eine form von uneingestandene
wertschätzung also derzeit verträgt es
nicht derjenige es erträgt es nicht
jemanden eigentlich wertschätzen zu
müssen so etwas was eigentlich gerade
dafür möchte sie sehen ganz komplexe
sache und auch über den ort kann man
sehr schön schreiben und eine
phänomenologie das was wir gemacht haben
waren keine erfindungen um die das war
so konstant ist immer beachten weil
jeder frauen des ttc
laut weil nicht alles
ich lade ich habe jetzt den vorteil
betrachten sie der täter von seinem
feldes mutter und ich denke kommt das
comfort gibt es ein gewisses opfer warum
weil wir nicht dem antrag etwas nicht
können was er oder sie eigentlich
verdient anerkennung und maifest
weigerung innere mal kunden je nach
jemandem anerkennend soll der ist
verdient aber wenn man das nicht erträgt
weil man eben sich selbst dadurch
geschmälert fühlen oder währungen es
gibt bestimmt mutig was könnte denn ein
motiv in ein zeit geblieben sind
und wir haben sieben zu schauen das ist
verhältnismäßig zu früheren worden
[Musik]
ja genau also er vor also man fühlt sich
selbst um gerecht also mann derjenige
meine schwester wenn ich von mir selbst
opfer zu sein
also das ist auch der punkt der einigung
ist der glaube seines umsatzes also es
hat auch was mit vertauschten grund sind
und der sieht sich selbst rom gerecht
behandelt alle reagiert auf diese
ungerechtigkeit die vielleicht
eingebildet ist die aber auch nicht sein
kann so dass er jemand anderem deswegen
etwas nicht können auch ungerecht wird
als ungerechtigkeit mit ungerechtigkeit
begegnen möchte und eine form so
moralisch gerechtfertigt natürlich nicht
gefallen ich gesehen dass man sie
kommentiert und ausgehalten die man
genauso um wie mit also jemand der
darüber stehen und es ist weiter punkte
das habe ich jetzt auch noch vergessen
zur täterin
diverse für eine minute und noch eine
tugend perspektive darauf werfen sich
immer fragen wie kann man denn dieser
form des unmoralischen dann entgehen
was sollte dem einleiten menschen tun
und sich zu bessern
was würden sie so jemandem sagen der
zeit habe ich bin ungerecht behandelt
worden und deswegen können extreme oder
heben
kann sich überlegen also wollte jetzt
muss man es auch noch einen gültigen
behandeln aber überlegen sich das auch
immer wie kann man diese form des
moralischen kubanischen lösen tun müssen
phänomenologie und jetzt will mini heißt
die verschiedenen formen zum beispiel
gibt es einen heimlichen leid
schauen sie mal was es für formen des
nein es gibt da gibt es ganz
verschiedene vergessenheit ist es gibt
nein des hass steigern gaben über links
immer diese betrifft alles die
phänomenologie die verschiedenen formen
der jeweiligen form
voraus buchen wenn sie zum beispiel
blätter in der literaturgeschichte und
den filmen können sie das gerne
mitnehmen
wir haben das ja schon beim geiles
gehabt und gewährte ganze dann blieb das
hi virus und wenn es eben passt ist
können sie sich gerne dieser ganz
reichhaltigen kulturellen tradition
bedienen
so und jetzt möchte ich noch mal ganz
kurz diese dieses schema und wächst hier
und hier
ich muss gestehen ich bin mir hier auch
noch nicht ganz sicher ob das der
weisheit letzter schluss ist wir haben
gesagt wir können form das moralische
keule vor unterscheiden äußerliche form
ist ganz klar eine handlung das ist
unstrittig
wo ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin und das
muss man auch diskutiert das verhalten
ich glaube dass ein verhalten nicht
nicht dasselbe ist die behandlung aber
man kann sich unmöglich halten ganz
höflich verhalten
das können zeichen seien die signale
seien die deutlich ausgesendet werden
zum beispiel meinen körper zum beispiel
auch das körper haben
ein verhalten ist was jetzt nicht
unbedingt meine handlungen ist kann ich
kann zum beispiel bedingt übrigens sind
auf einem anlass die treffen jemanden
und sie weigert sich dem oder ihr die
hand zu geben und speditionen ich würde
sagen dass das ist moralisch der weg des
kann bevor man sich auf drin aber es ist
zumindest ohne und sie würden aber erst
sagen es war ein verhalten das war nicht
mehr handlung wir haben da es auch immer
punktuell behandlung ganz lang und
hände und verhalten zieht sie ihr so
durch würde ich sagen verhalten ist ein
grundeinstellungen die sich nach außen
derzeit auch eine spannende sache von
der haushalt immer ein bisschen
vorbereitet ich gebe zu es ist noch
damals
perfekt also da werden sie bestimmten
eine damen- und die könnten dann in der
hausarbeit oder folgende immer an bringt
also verhalten mit die unterscheidung
einhaltung der haltung würde ich sagen
ist ihr was widerliches es geht aber
auch um es im krisen in der welt eine
haltung die kann jemanden ein und nehmen
zu bestimmten bedingungen zu bestimmten
themen aber die haltung müsse nicht
unbedingt seiten zum beispiel glaube ich
das leid auch was fatale tournee zum
beispiel ein muss nicht nur leitet ist
auch eine haltung zu jemandem nämlich
ein erhaltung des verweigerten
anerkennung und das verweigern von
anerkennung es eigentlich nicht ein
gefühl aber es ist nicht unbedingt
verhalten
ich meine wir haben ja gesehen jemandem
breiteste musste es nicht zeigen
unbedingt manchmal ist sie gar nicht das
thema
draußen und wenn sie es müssten wie
gesagt wenn der oder die jetzt gesagt
würde jährlich danzig das wirken sie
sich wahrscheinlich geschmeichelt fühlen
man eventuell also bei mir wäre es
vielleicht als erhaltung und dann ganz
klar noch erfüllt emotionen tief da kann
man natürlich auch noch darunter
unterscheiden
aber ich würde sagen dass diese motive
als jede verhandlung lebenserhaltende
behandlung für jeden antun können sie
befragen
auch die relativ welches motiv lag
dieser handlung zu gründen das ist
glaube ich so können sie den unterschied
ganz klar eine motiv kann natürlich
wiederholen motive zugrunde liegen aber
die innerlichkeit basis des lebens
also nicht
dass man sein
er ist manchmal ganz hinten
basis ist die motive und die haben dann
stehen und auf dieser basis die motive
sind nur das 100
ohne diese motive kommen ja gar nicht um
der handlung wird bewerten zu können
müssen immer die motive wissen der
handlung selbst filme die motive ganz an
es kann mord aus ganz verschiedenen
motiven stadt trier kommt am morgen als
ich habe ich habe jetzt erst mal eine
zusammenfassung
übrigens jeder und jede von ihnen
bekommen falls nicht schreibt eine
e-mail die habe ich noch dringender viel
okas bei mir können sie sich eben jene
unter wahrung und gab es auch die ganzen
zusammenfassung und schön
hoffentlich schönen grafiken also
handlungen clown der scheinbar aktien
raumzeit ein bestimmtes ziel verfolgen
oder es gibt eine theologie ihre
intention kate gerichtet verhalten ist
nicht unbedingt so sehr gerichtet und
nicht so sehr dem vertrag endlich system
[Musik]
abgrenzt darauf äußerlich war zeichnete
signale die agentur aus und die auf eine
haltung jener lichkeit oder absicht
schließen lassen auch wenn diese nicht
klar zutage dass besitzen tritt muss
klein geschrieben werden das ist
natürlich jetzt nur in versuchen haltung
ist glaube ich schon klar zu definieren
haltung wäre eine innere einstellung
oder maxime die sich nicht unbedingt als
verhalten zu anderen zeiten muss das ist
die proposition ahl verfassten position
ahl bedeutet das kann ein
das salz bringen zum beispiel bringt
gleich spielen er glaubt dass neid neid
was von den positionen einstellen dass
der/die mehr hat oder besser dastehen
das ist ungerecht dass das was das ist
der sachverhalt und gefühle zum motiv
motiven wie gesagt passenden begriffen
aber man sagt man mir so triebfedern
triebfeder mit seiner automotive innere
gemüt stimmung die verborgen existieren
ganz ist nicht unbedingt professional
gefasst es gibt mit ganz große
diskussion in der emotion story ob
gefühle emotionen proposition ahl
erfasst sie einem das salz aus ob sie
eine kognitive seite da habe ich nicht
unbedingt müssen nicht alle gefühle
haben nicht alle gefühle sind
manche gefühle sind für nationale punkte
jetzt habe ich ein paar beispiele
handlung mord ganz klar ist vielleicht
die thematische handlung bis heute
leiden wird schon schwieriger
dort ist nämlich deswegen so
paradigmatisch an bord einfach zu einem
kunden dass das passiert da wird die
marktchancen und ausland wenden wenn der
mord zu lange dauert was ist es dann
und es nicht mehr wort sondern
vielleicht auch nur dann würden wir es
anders bezeichnen mit dem wort auch zehn
stunden dauert wurde dann wärst du kein
wort mehr was würden sie dann seiner
freude genau der quälerei als im rolls
ganz klar mord muss schon
morgens zu passieren wenn man eine
eigene sitzung dazu ich will jetzt keine
anleihen und natürlich geben also fort
muss ziemlich wild auf einem tisch
musste das tier dann muss das land
abgeschlossen
und wenn das denn das nicht ist dann ist
ein misslungener morgen oder wenn jemand
sich zu lange zeit festen ort wenn es
ist eben kein wort mehr sagen folge also
nix sagt mord mobbing im objekt eine
typische typische nordische handlung
auch wenn moment ich so klar zu tage
tritt wieder an bord weil der rock
sicher gar nicht täuschen im ort gibt an
dem ort wo der mörder entzieht sich
meinem versuchten mord an raffiniert zu
machen das stimmt schon dass man das
gefasst wird aber die tat betroffen und
zutage während mobbing vier profilierte
geschehen kann
wir machen heute
dann verhalten schamlosigkeit
unverschämt
das bringt möglichkeit gesehen dass er
sich unbedingt direkt vors huber strecke
ihr unverständnis musste um warstein
jetzt auch was sagen sie man ist immer
unterstellt
das ist eine unverschämtheit
ja
[Musik]
okay okay also man wieder mehr als man
macht unverstellt hohe forderungen oder
so was man als ohne übertriebenen maße
genommen wurde oder sie möchten
unverschämt unterstellt abreise gen
restaurant und werde noch gesucht werden
und dann würden sie mich gleich sagen
dass es unmoralisch wissen aber wie sagt
man da nicht dabei da gibt's dann
begriffen jetzt gerade verein das ist
irgendwas nicht
das ist wider vielleicht kommt ja immer
so was also der sommerzeit
er ist so ein bisschen an der grenze
respektlosigkeit war also das ist eine
spannende frage
ich glaube dass ich schamlosigkeit
unverschämtheit eben noch aus der zeit
aber das muss unbedingt behandlung ist
wenn sie in dem restaurant etwas zu hohe
preise verlangt
dann können sie nicht sagen das
restaurant handeln und leben nicht damit
mehr handlungs und versammelten
verhalten oder seinem kontext des
restaurants der auf seinem buch und cd
oder in verschiedenen schließen also
frage ich mich jetzt haltung der hat was
von der haltung haben wir gesagt ja muss
ich nicht daraus zeigen aber leider auch
eine emotionale komponente
manche sagen der neuzeit mit einem
bestimmten farbe verbunden denn neid die
wird auch ästhetisch behandelt was immer
darauf hinweist dass man emotional
er hat würden sie die emotionen
beschreiben die entscheidende rolle
spielt das ist die phänomenologische
frage welche gefühle haben es die
perfekte oder sagt immer wenn sie
neidisch dass ein baum das gefühl kaltes
gefühl könnte es beschreiben
und das ist gar kein gefühl sagt die
vorher gibt es eine meine wenn sie mal
nach 1984 auf youtube wie lässt sich
neid von einem tatsächlich berechtigten
um gerechtigkeit sind wieder schalten
ist leider einmal angucken berichtete
ungerechtigkeitsempfinden gebunden
werden und weiter spielt die
selbsttäuschung ohne es selbst heute
schon die wollte ich noch dazu sagen
man kann er tatsächlich selbst ungerecht
behandelt werden
es mag ja stimmen dass man um gewicht
behalten aber dennoch sollte man
natürlich aus moralischer sicht nicht
neidisch sein
also wenn jetzt zb jemand doppelt so
viel verdient wie man selbst in diesem
beispiel über diskriminierung aus dem
handel um woanders gibt es beispiele
eines automobilherstellers wurde für
dieselbe arbeit unwahrscheinlich viel
geld bezahlt und das wird als halter
diskriminierung dar so es geht zurück
ich will jetzt keine unternehmen
betriebs dass dieselben dieselben
leistungen je nachdem wo man angestellt
ist eben denselben unternehmensangaben
deutlich erkennbar sein
dessen fahrer ein bisschen aber ich
glaube es aber selbst dann wenn man
ungerecht behandelt wird ist es noch
keinen grund dafür kein gerechtfertigten
grund neidisch zu sein
also was kann denn der andere dafür
würde die andere wenn sie ordentlich
bezahlt und ich mich das ist die falsche
reaktion also selbst wenn man neidisch
ist aus einem berechtigten was heißt was
an um aus anlass der in dem man selbst
ungerecht behandelt wird gerechtfertigt
dass er nicht alleine da muss man keine
der anderen
[Musik]
man muss die sache hat euch anders reden
also ich glaube aber auch die frage noch
mal dass der inhalt wesentlich noch mit
selbst schon zu tun hat in der regel
wird man nicht ungerecht behandelt in
der regel ist wird der andere nicht um
geld überweise berechtigterweise die
grundsätze der regel besteht man sich
nicht ein fast an den rand um eigentlich
wertschätzen möchte ich dass die anderen
über eine eigenschaft reiner guth
verfügt um die das wird auch geräte und
was man aber nicht sich eingestehen
möchte dass der andere vielleicht
wirklich besser ist als man selbst aber
es nicht erträgt dass es besser ist das
ist glaube ich die regel aber man wird
es nie als nein zu geben sondern würde
sich immer selbst löschen einer
selbsttäuschung unterliegen und würde es
münchen und sagen ja aber eigentlich bin
ich doch genauso gut sogar besser aber
will diese umstände wieder
ungerechtigkeit sich selbst als opfer
position das ist doch ungerecht also der
mai deutlich sagen dass noch ungewiss
ist umgelegt
aber was noch mal zurück zum gefühl des
neides dazu
hier zu latenten zorn hast für ihre
augen
genau das könnte überlegt und hass und
so etwas würde ich jetzt hier auch keine
zeit
bei hast natürlich intentional ead.etr
das gericht ich hasse den oder die aber
hat nicht so sinne proposition aale
einstellung und rat brauche ich
schadenfreude glaube ich auch nicht
wobei stoff wurde auch eine haltung ist
entscheiden es ist klar und als deswegen
schadenfreude und sehe ich auch so ein
bisschen viel später das tote des hatte
schadenfreude als ein effekt an dessen
aussehen es wird schwierig deswegen zur
sicherheit einfach sagen müssen dass sie
innerlich ist diese unterscheidung
zwischen äußerlich ziemlich jedes spiel
gab ihm recht
es gehört zur migration auch ziemlich
klar zu machen dass nicht halten
das ist ein gefühl des staates
intensives gefühl einfach gut hat was
von wright wird immer schwieriger weil
besuchten aber auch neben unserer zeit
ja das ist was spielt da eine einfache
suche vielleicht sogar neid oder
also spannend können sie für sich
überlegen können sie den bauch und
hausarbeit drüber schreiben also das ist
element mit minus gelegen sollte im
laufe des semesters hier eine ziemlich
klar eine klassifikation hinzubekommen
wäre viel gewonnen weil das meine es ist
dringlich unternehmen etwas zu machen so
jetzt immer noch das wort wir machen das
zimmer nord mord strafgesetzbuch
paragraf zwei mal wählen der mörderin
mit lebenslange freiheitsstrafe bestraft
mörder ist und wir sind das jetzt gerade
ist er aus dem rolls zur befriedigung
des geschlechtstriebs aus habgier oder
sonst muss niedrig beweggründen
heimtückisch grausam oder mit
gemeingefährlichen
oder eine andere straftat zu ermöglichen
oder zu verdecken einen menschen tötet
und jetzt sieht sie hier die ganze liste
an form des umweltverbundes innerlich
betrifft was wir mit dem innerlichen ab
ja niedrige beweggründe zbz meines
wissens auch rassismus zum niedrigen
beweggründen zabern im spannenden frage
habt ihr damals sünde hier sogar habt
ihr das wird alles niedriger beweggrund
gesehen grausamkeit ist auch eine form
des unmoralischen ja ist grausam kein
besseres grausamkeit
das ist eine handlung sind das ist ein
motiv ist nicht weg wenn es draußen kalt
ist wissen einstellungen wurde das
verhalten zeigten verhalten grausamkeit
ist ein modus in denen eine handlung
geschehen kann
ich würde sagen kann ist keine handlung
sind es einen modus eine hand
es gibt nur kurz zurück ist das machen
ich glaube dass das verhalten der fotos
in dem meine haltung stattfinden kann
und deswegen würde ich jemandem eines
tages auch mehr spielt
das muss glaube ich halt und
die hand rassistisch rang als ist der
modus das qualifiziert die handlung mehr
bekommt das sagt man der daumen aber wir
wollen auf dem board hinweise hier
werden genau diese motive im fall des
mordes an weil sonst wäre es ja nur
deutschland wenn es dir etwas anderes
wenn diese merkmale wirst du sehen die
rechtswissenschaft auch gedanken dazu
so jetzt noch ganz kurz zu möglichen
haus arbeitsthemen weil wir wollen wir
auch unten sind konkret werden sie
können zb sich dem problem der höhe
gewinnen
da können sie arten strategien in der
höhe und die straftat martin auch noch
verwenden sprach abartigkeit verfügt der
spiel mit der sprache der macht er mit
dann könnten sie untersuchen liefern ein
generelles wettverbot philosophisch
plausibel ist denkt sie anerkannte
zurück das könnte schon diskutieren
welche gründe hat
bekannt und diese tiere sind wie lassen
sich die form des unmoralischen
klassifizieren das betrifft diese frage
begleitet private ganze muss seine form
motive der diskriminierung bekommen
heute tropf diskriminierungen deswegen
macht es entstehen zudem reformen
maschine von mobbing also wie kann sich
moby gestalten welche struktur hat
mobbing denken sie immer daran wenn sie
nicht unter so philosophisch
interessante auswahl schreiben sollten
sie immerhin jeder form diese behandelt
in jeder form das ungleiche ein
rationales kultur entdecken das ist
jetzt etwas plakativ aber wenn sie
philosophisch interessantes herausfinden
sollten sie nur unterstellung dass
dieses phänomen was wir analysieren
rational ist und es fällt uns natürlich
beim moralisch höchst und dem
albanischen generell zu erschweren weil
wir geneigt zu sagen das ist ja an sich
schon wieder zu machen das böse oder
orange kann der gar keine gründe haben
aber diese voraussetzung müssen sie
machen weil sonst können sie gar nicht
drüber schreiben sonst können sie
höchstens darüber dichter oder
komponieren oder sonst nicht mal dass
sie müssen immer unterstellen dass diese
form eine rationalität impliziert und
ich glaube dass es der fall
schauen sie mal weniger gut der ist zwar
total
die größten verbrecher will verbrecher
beim csd motto vielleicht auch ein paar
cent auf andere nehmen in anderen sicht
nicht so aber dann muss der ganze mit
eine rolle spielt und um diese
rationalität sonst sollte es unter
anderem geben nicht nur aber auch zum
beispiel können sie auch noch in
besucher neben die formen das ist eine
empfehlung geht es dem mittelstand aber
auch die motive von die strategie spiele
bereit zwischen gefühl und einstellungen
moralismus ein lieblingsthema moralismus
als perversion dem ural und alles musste
ganz spannendes thema beim moralismus
öffnet sich dann eben zum terrorismus
und zum fanatismus
also man könnte zum beispiel sich
überlegen wie aus moralismus stellt
terrorismus wird das ist wenn ich eine
ganz ganz spannende frage wie das mal an
gegensatz dazu nächste sie zu machen wir
keine chance
morales mit und so weiter und so fort
dass es einige möglicherweise sie sich
schützen könnten
kurz vor dazu bitte nehmen sie immer
kontakt mit mir auf bevor sie das haus
arbeitszimmer endgültig bearbeiten
schreiben sie eine e mail bekommen in
der sprechstunde schicken sie mir
explosion
bitte keine gliederung damit fange ich
nicht so viel also nicht eine gliederung
ist immer ein exposé also einer seite
und eine halbe dass das problem dar
umsonst gehen und so weiter einfach dass
ich den grundgedanken okay jetzt noch
ein letzter punkt der novelle zum thema
nicht ich habe jetzt an tz ich sage dass
die unmoralische handlungen durch kleine
schnitte ist eine funktion ihrer
ungewaschen motive was ist damit gemeint
die serie moralische handlung zb ein
rekord kann aufgrund ganz
unterschiedlichen motiven begangen hause
fuhren wir sehen in dem kauf 200
strafgesetzbuch der mordopfer aus dem
niederen beweggründen und sofort kam in
siders und man kann für uns nur gewohnt
keine pause ich weiß nicht was nach dem
motto aus neid und eifersucht
herausgegeben und dann gemeint ist wie
so eine funktion zu setzen und sie
willkommen hieß und ausstiegsoption und
verschiedene hören war wieder einsetzen
und dann bekommen sie was aus aber sie
können von der handlung nicht auf die
motive schließt man das könnte
das ist also eine neigung eindeutigen
zuordnung fast wie eine funktion
ich kann dem morgen mit ansehen was
seine gründe waren
ich kann aber auch letztendlich wenn ich
die motive haben den mord in erklärung
wie genau er das meine thesen sie hier
skeptische blicke völlig berechtigt ist
noch diskussionsvorlage zum beispiel ort
aus neid eifersucht rache hass rassismus
antisemitismus und aus
mischungsverhältnis
und verschiedenen routen so und jetzt
kommen wir endlich zwischen thema
die vorsitzende norbert genau als
mobbing und zwar mit fragen des
ständigen rates allerdings der mord
gewöhnlich wen und warum und wo und
liefern ist mobbing objektiv
feststellbar und nicht nur ein
subjektiver eindruck wie könnte ein
typischer fall von mobbing aussieht
welche psychischen physischen strategie
werden von seiten der täterinnen und
täter dazu bekennen
wie empfindet und erlebe des fastens
morgen ganz wichtig immer auch die
opferperspektive einbeziehen
auch wenn die natürlich in meinen augen
mit griffin abgeleitet ist als
begrifflich sind wir wenn wir und das
verletzung des koreanischen roman es
geht um sich in der erklärung
es müssen nicht immer auch gegenseitig
im wege spieler zu moralischen
berücksichtigen also das verfahren
schafft immer dem täter in der bank von
zeit welche interessen und werte werden
durch das mobbing verletzt beim
das ist nämlich auch wichtig darauf
hatte auch arnd peiffer den
verwandlungen nur hingerissen
das ist es wurden das ist jetzt nicht so
streng wissenschaftlich beschrieben
fungieren populärwissenschaftlich ein
handbuch mobilität ist in planung und
beim jetzt kommen zwei jahren aus und
wird das ganze noch ein bisschen genauer
beschrieben und dem seminar diskussion
die wir hier jetzt gerade erleben eine
fast so wenn ein paar gänse sich
zusammentun um ihren gemeinsamen vereint
dem fuchs laut schnatternd den tag zur
bewerbung spricht die verhaltensbiologie
von mobbing konrad lorenz zwar als der
berühmte verhaltensforschung
denn sein
60 erschienen das sogenannte böse eine
der tierwelt keineswegs zehntes phänomen
vor augen hat ein aggressives jeweils
spezifische gruppen verhalten gegenüber
einem als feindlich empfundenen
eindringen das motto lautet gemeinsam
ist man stark
dann bilden eine art tierische
terrorgruppen und verpasst den
verhassten konnte einen denkzettel
indem man den psychologischen in
psychologische kampf verwickelt
das ist der kompromiss dass sie alt
geworden und jetzt würde ich gerne
tanzen zu fragen wie wann ist denn
problematisch solche verhaltensweisen
die reichen auf die normalen des
vertrages
ja genau
wir können dies war ergänzte ihr das
bild warum auch die daher dem fuchs
gemobbt sondern er wird sagen das liegt
neben mit der natur der gänse sich zu
verteidigen
und jetzt bezogen auf uns wenn jetzt
angenommen wir hier jemanden machen
würden sagte schon an der universität zu
wenig gemacht wissen sie warum genau man
kann jederzeit aus der tür ausgehen im
hörsaal wird sehr selten geworden kann
er einfach ausgehen gibt ja keine
anwesenheitspflicht beleben ist dagegen
sehr viel gemacht
wir hatten das kurz behandeln das geht
auch gemacht und ist oder problemen
der raum der lau der immunität kann sich
unzufrieden
der raum der dem ordnete es müssten nur
bewegungen in welchem raum in welchem
kontext kann überhaupt diese form des
unmoralischen auftreten ganz genau
also zum beispiel am arbeitsplatz das
mit dem fx und know how in der schule
genommen der schule können sie sich
getrost ausgehen wenn sie das machen wir
kommen sie in eintragen lassen
erscheint also in der schule sind wir
auch ziemlich aufeinander angewiesen
1000 hoch der wert könnte vielleicht in
dem c29 nicht weg aber dann muss man
wieder zusammen sein risiko passiert nur
bis sehr häufig bekommen der schule und
am arbeitsplatz
und hier zum guten nicht zu sehr genau
also amazon lorenz problematisch weil
wir bei tieren wie es im ok verhalten
nie passiert würde ich gar nicht um
wahlen statt sich zu prüfen
wer das ist einfach nicht
und adäquate inhalt adäquat übertragen
von natürlichen kategorien auf unsere
moralische lebensmittel und der lorenz
geht aber so weit dass er sagt es gibt
nur das so genannte gemüse
ich glaube das macht den fehler uns
menschen zu sehr dass tiere sind zwar
tiere aber wir sind eben moralischen
tiere
wir haben eben eine ganz andere
lebensformen und wir haben ihr lebens
man die lieben normativ ist die auf
freiheit und viele dieser
verhaltensforscher sehen gibt den
menschen zu sehr nahe am tierreich weil
sie eben die freiheit sprechen und wenn
man natürlich die menschen die freiheit
abspricht dann ist er natürlich nur noch
ein tier und dann sind alle moralischen
form allein erklärt munitionsdepot
aber ich glaube dass es immer mal tätig
gerecht wird
weil ich glaube dass mir die form des
umgangs spricht hat die quad bezeichnet
wenn wir nur als wenn wir sie als formel
unserer biologie betracht ich glaube
dass es ein gerechtfertigter werden zu
lassen und das böse ist für konrad
lorenz auch nur eine natürliche
biologische kategorie nämlich was was
dazu führt dass
die arten ihren jeweiligen lebensraum
voneinander abgrenzen also letztendlich
ist das böse für kommandant natürlich
gesehen etwas sehr sinnvolles etwas
produktives wird aber dadurch den bösen
nicht gerecht wenn man es mal betrachten
da hatte ich bin da sehr skeptisch dass
das alles zum ansehen kann jedenfalls
hatte den begriff geprägt
im raum von norbert untersuchen hat
diese dann zunächst beobachten können
dass tierische smog ev drei
unterschiedlichen varianten ausführen
kann man die tiere zb jene gehen diese
setzen sich gemeinsam gegen alles fremde
fressfeinde zu wir denen es im einzelnen
hilflos ausgeliefert
andere theater zu machen schicken ihre
konkurrenten aus dem eigenen reihen
wieder andere stürzen sich gezielt auf
schwächeren pia so wurde lorenz selbst
einziger mitsangen und für eine horde
rindern eingekreist bis er mit 250 zu
einem beherzten sprung den anbieter
gezwungen sah er hat es ist natürlich
würde niemand sagen ich wurde von einer
herde rinder das niemand sagen
das sagen wir wurden angegriffen wurden
attackiert und zwar wie jetzt schulden
der talente lorenz mit salzburg wären
diese diesen raum ein getrenntes ist
völlig verständlich wie es manchmal
technologie wie kann man diese analogie
dieser dieser rinder und lorenz wie kann
man das jetzt analoges beziehen auch
unsere leben zuwenden arbeitsplatz
arbeitsplatz
[Musik]
genau das ist der typische fall jemandem
kommt neue arbeitsplatz und wird dann
gebaut und die gruppe wesentlich sagen
es ist auf eine abgestimmte eingestellt
und jetzt wird dieses dieses system
scheinbar ebenfalls gestört also dass
der neue die neue wird als eindringling
machen und wenn dadurch ein besonders
geräumt das kann man natürlich sagen
dass er hat einige natur hier nur einer
evolutionären grund als man kann
natürlich sagen dass wir so reagiert auf
neue und mitarbeiter ist irgendwie in
der theologie mit unserer genetischen
angebot bestimmt aber das ändere nichts
daran dass wir uns dazu frei verhalten
können vielleicht mögen die tendenz
haben neue mitglieder neue mitte
weitere neue kollegin irgendwie als
eindringling re store zu sehen
auch als konkurrenten und ich denke auch
das thema eifersucht eine wurde spielt
also das thema einfach und auch mit dem
mobbing zusammen
aber das ist natürlich was passiert
schreibt damit ein nutzer weil sie nicht
verstehen dass sich das problem auf den
muss ich überlegen anfangs beziehen ist
ich denke ist nicht klar
klassischerweise der fall das hobby nach
unten gerichtet auseinander um die stadt
finden das ist ein interessanter dem
natürlichen das mobil von owens ist eben
sehr schwache form die nicht genau an
als analogie gesehen werden kann es geht
hier um den mord was ist der morgen
einen mord ist gruppe
ja sagt man also eine gruppe die
aggressiven auftritt vielleicht sehr
geschlossen das meint das bedeute
geschlossene erschlossene aggression das
ist natürlich im moralischen morgen auch
der fall der regel geht es um das
anderssein punkte sind es gibt
orientierung seine diese karten messen
oder auch jetzt kann und es kann jetzt
so sein dass keiner gehen eine gruppe 1
die wende ein opfer an den coup ein
europa ohne einwände gegen eine gruppe
ist ganz schön und es ist natürlich kaum
noch dieses verhältnis das die da so auf
sich selbst beziehen ist auch für mich
direkt präsent ist moment geht es
traditionell zur selbsttäuschung
keine probleme hatte selbst frischem
unternehmens gehört es immer noch mit
dazu die frage ist ob selbst zerschnitt
ein solches uno erschließen muss die
juni zahlen aber aus der selbsttäuschung
präsentieren lebens sehr schnell
zum beispiel geeignet sind aber wir
wollten wir mal dass ergänzt zug ist
also wie gesagt alle trifft es nicht
ganz genau
die hier nirgends vornimmt und ja also
man verspürt sich gewissermaßen gegen
jemanden der als eindringlinge
wahrgenommen weil er dieses system
irgendwie durcheinander als es sprechen
die gruppe ist nicht flexibel genug und
tolerant genug oder ich höflich genug
wasser als nicht nicht genug um diese
neue person zu begrüßen hat man ja
eigentlich täten was wäre denn jetzt mal
nochmals ein motiv was könnte jetzt hier
nochmal die gruppe sich denken ihm
doping am arbeitsplatz
wie finden sie eine mobi land überlegen
sind wenn sie jetzt jemand wohnen
was macht sie nicht sie aber was könnte
diese imaginäre täter ja genau so genau
zum beispiel beginnt es dann beim kaffee
oder man sagt du musst ja schon ein
sprecher dafür wurde oder kaffee gibt es
erst wenn man fünf jahre gute preise
oder wie man dazu wenn man jemanden zb
informationen vorerst also ihm nicht an
dem informationsfluss westen vor allem
natürlich auch die kommunikation um
geben oder sie herum also eben dieses
ausgrenzen auch in der kommunikation
dann könnte ein nächster schritt sein
das erleben etwas stichelt sprich eben
auch das schild dieses tor schritten
dieses hinten herum und dass man
vielleicht auch dieses opfer gewissem
maße stigmatisiert und diskriminiert
oder dass man schaut
inwiefern unterscheidet sich denn jetzt
dieser branding diese neue personen
von uns gibt es bestimmte merkmale an
ihm moderierte sie an der man die man
anknüpfen kann um sie eben noch mehr zu
unterschreiten die situation das geht
ganz schön auch so ein bisschen
diskriminierung das werk ganz bestimmten
merkmalen und schalen die dann zum
anlass wert mit in abgrenzung werden wir
bisher das leben weiterführen zu können
das hat als auch was in einem zeitungs
ist ihm dieses modell also
diskriminierung spielte glaube schon
aber so verschiedene spielarten
tierischen mobbings auch sein mögen
schwächeren stärkere gleichstarken
gleich stark hersteller gegen schwächere
shuttles geht es dauern den verhassten
gegner einzuschüchtern oder heben das
leben sauer zu
das mag ein gut geht und eine
vergleichbare vorgänge der menschen
bildet dabei der begriff gruppen
mobilisieren
lorenz auftauchen ist eher das gegenteil
sagen was man heute der menschen mit als
moment bezeichnet werden uns an die vier
welt die beispiellose karriere deshalb
berichten und mindestens 1 eine
bezeichnung
man kann menschliche und haben gilt als
erst viel später und zwar mit dessen
übertragen auf spezifische hinter
personal zusammenhänge durch den
schweden schied jahre schulungen heinz
reimann
diese ganze thematik spielen auch
psychologie mit raimund natürlich auch
und die inflation zu geben und 80er
jahren hatte dieser finanziert durch
schwedische gewerkschaften dem offenbar
das wohl ihrer arbeiter bin und arbeit
am herzen lag bahnbrechende studie zur
täglichen terror am arbeitsplatz
durchgeführt dabei hatte dreimal fenster
müssen der zahllose zahllose
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer von
ihren unmittelbaren vorgesetzten oder
auch kollegen massiv schikaniert weit
wichtiger brille verschicken oder musik
sie haben
ohne dass die gründe dafür ersichtlich
gewesen wären um dieses phänomen und den
grund zu gehen
die flammen gekämpft zurück und
entwickelte daraus einen
sozialpsychologischen untersuchen muss
rahmen der später losgehen wird es heute
wegweisend ist also immens hat nicht
direkt ins diese übertragung vorgenommen
aber beides findet sich in meinen augen
schon eine gewisse übertragung geben die
aber nicht gerechtfertigt es niemand
anders sogenannten bösen sind
interessant ist hier zunächst dass sich
auch schon verlorenes parallele zwischen
noventa tieren und vergleichbare vor den
matches wellen finden
lorenz sprach von einem aggressiven und
an psychoterror grenzenden
revierverhalten das aus verhaltens
gesicht vor allem dazu dienen soll den
einzelnen tieren und möglichst gleiche
weise über den vorhandenen lebens und
nahrungs und zu verteilen das ist
tatsächlich der grund den lorenz auch im
so genannten ko system
und eben dieses revierverhalten
vertragslosen zu hause eigentlich mit
angehenden herzen kaufen und fahrern
sich haben kann
die bei der neueröffnung ihrer geschäfte
stets auch darauf zu achten hätten sich
möglichst weit vom nächsten kommen
komponenten anzubieten damit niemandem
das ist natürlich eine problematische
vertrag und wir können doch neben ich
meine so macht man sich auch tier
kapitalismus und so weiter aber ich
glaube dass hier unterschätzt werden wie
durch synergien oder durch kooperationen
geben noch die größen erreicht werden
dieses fragments und wir müssen
kooperieren
und dann gibt es wieder die effekte die
wir noch gar nicht absehen wenn man
immer nur dem konkurrenzmodell bleiben
kommen wir nie auf den gedanken ich
glaube die kooperation ist das
entscheidung denn sobald man sich mit
seinen geschäften wechselseitigen die
quere kommen für das ökonomische und
sofort ist ein aggressiver
konkurrenzkampf im fachmann streit um
einen guten platz am futtertrog das
heißt um marktanteile und so werden
offene feindseligkeit wie sie für
tierisches machen
typisch sind kaum ausgleichen können
doch wie beiträgt diese
ich glaube nicht dass hier lumen und die
ganzen anderen die oppositionsgruppe
unterschätzen dass der freie wesen sind
probieren können und die einsicht haben
in gründe und so weiter der ausdruck
mobbing historische substantiven mauer
ab genannten das türme über gesunde mit
um das werk zum morgen einen
dementsprechenden pöbel sich
zusammenrotten wurde übernehmen
dabei muss das revier das gemeinsam
gegen unliebsame einträge verteidigt
werden so nicht immer nur der eigene
arbeitsplatz war bereits im kindergarten
stimmen kindergarten noch vergessen in
der schule und in der eigen-pr grund
wird gemauert und universitäten nicht zu
sehr in krankenhäusern sicherlich und
gefängnissen beim regieren militär
sicherlich auch in vereinen und dateien
und neuerdings auch im internet wo es
der begriff zahlungen binden
eingebürgert hat so was sie
es sei damit allerdings immer man könnte
auch sagen im internet können wir doch
viel besser entfleucht im internet sind
wir doch nicht trauen zeitlich verein
dem zweck wie wir es in einer
schulstunde oder auf dem pausenhof sind
dem meeresarm ausreichen könnten gar
nicht verlassen werden sich noch an ihre
schulzeit wenn sie dem dem inneren ab
einem bestimmten alter vor allem
gestanden hatte dass studierende
verlesen sofern das tat begangen zu
haben weil sie nicht mehr versichert und
der lehre wird also eine aufsichts
machen musste während es ein aufsichts
bieten jetzt aber im internet gibt es
doch nicht diesen zeitlichen kämpfen
warum ist dann das internet gerade
arbeit genannt aber dennoch deren ein
neuer ort des mobils geworden
[Musik]
genau das ist es haben sie noch andere
ideen wie kann man jemanden cyber
mobilisieren müssen er wolle sich zu
viele tipps geben aber sie haben es alle
schon gesagt dann stellen wir auch tun
auf hingegen die sich das opfer gar
nicht mehr richtig verteidigen kann weil
es ja nicht erlauben zeitlich zu geben
ist wir haben jetzt zwei spielminuten
jemanden von ihnen würden was drauf
werfen würde erstellen würde was nicht
stimmen sie verneinte übrigens auch noch
industrie verwaltung dann würde es seien
aber das stimmt doch gar nicht mehr
aufstehen würden es wendet sich an die
anderen windows sagt hier ich habe hier
dem zeuge den zeugen
das ist eine stimme das können sie im
internet natürlich nicht mehr macht
internet haben sie nicht mehr
eine solche kommunikationsstruktur dass
sie dagegen einspruch einlegen können
und das ist also ein punkt man kann
natürlich bauer kompromittierende
dokumente die auch gefälscht sein kann
vielleicht einen großen publikum
zugänglich machen
das internet obwohl es nicht traumzeit
zu verpassen
unsere lebenswelt zum anspruch der
schule und am arbeitsplatz bietet die
möglichkeit von eur in all diesen
sozialen brennpunkten kann es zu
spannungen kommen und gelegentlich
werden die konflikte offen thematisieren
oder auch mit fäusten ausgetragen werden
unterdrückt und gedeckelt dann werden
sie sich eher unterschwellig am rechen
und so in versteckte bosheit subtile
gehässigkeiten oder lebens sukzessive
auf psycho terror ausnahme zwischen
untersuchungen haben gezeigt dass die
gefahr zum opfer zu werden umso größer
ist je stärker der betreffenden
brennpunkt hereinschauen ist jetzt das
thema auf die frau offenbar den
orientierte einer sozialen ausgleich
bevor der eigene verlust der hand
anspielt dass man klar ist fungieren dem
ziel die gemeinheiten die
nach einem sündenbock ausgeht als
wildtier wert auf diesen wichtigen
aspekten konnte das ist jetzt alles
sicherlich psychologischen interessant
wir mit als philosophie und religion
müssen 300 ist der philosophische grund
dahinter
wir sind ja keine psychologen das ist
ein druckausgleich und so weiter dann
kommen wir nicht weiter es soll das über
berücksichtigten hausarbeit sie können
durchaus auch immense motive in den
blick nehmen
y wie ein geht es geht gar nicht
aber was wir hier betreiben ist
psychologie nicht gehalten
das wollte er nur nochmals sagen also da
muss man doch mal eine ebene tiefer dann
einsteigen als nur eine von
soziologischen überhaupt zu werden
zuvor muss jedoch erklärt er wo genau
der punkt zu machen ist an dem einfachen
vertrag
die harmlose groß und gemeinheit in
winterschlaf
denn nicht schon jeder fläche scherz auf
arbeitsplatz das ist ein akt von
psychoterror und von morgen zu sprechen
um von dort sprechen zu können müssen
mindestens vier bedingungen erfüllt sagt
dass jetzt instanzen geklagt so das
opfer muss wiederholt längeren zeitraum
hinweg systematisch und aus meter weg
rücken mit gemeinheiten taktiert anders
gesagt eine singuläre temporäre planlose
und das nämlich euro förmlich als kopien
gezeigt wird das ist doch ein
interessanter punkt ziemliches genauso
als immobilienstrategie haben
mobbing muss systematisch vor sich gehen
und das mobbing systematisch vor sich
geht heißen
das ist ja auch mit einer bestimmten
form von rationalität zu tun haben
also habe ich es nichts was man
unbedingt leicht fällt es mag zwar den
moralischen täter vielleicht freude oder
heinrich spaß bereiten
jemanden systematisch zu traktieren aber
nicht damit auseinandersetzen müssen
eine dramaturgie drehbuchentwürfe mobile
funktioniert nach gewissen regeln
ich glaube das hat es wirklich immer
längeren zeitraum hinweg sind praktisch
einzel handlungen der mit ihr sich immer
wiederholen
die dms einen raum arbeit und einmal den
sich immer als sehr konkret
vorlesungsboykotts arbeitsraum mit raum
eine tochter auf die nahende sie sich
versteckten angriff vollziehen
aber noch nicht die gewohnte presse wir
haben hier im raum gewesen
zu sagen
und hier verschiedene und es hat ein
bisschen
ausbildung
[Musik]
und die haben eine gewisse muss ein
muster immer dann immer beim mittag ist
schon was ritualisiert dass das zeigen
die niederen beweggründe
[Musik]
auch meine youtube zuschauer was sind
die niederen beweggründe von ja wie kann
man das noch
ich komme auch so nennen die selbst
erhebung selbst selbstprofilierung gut
ja
ja nein und außen versuchen oder
missgunst gegenüber dem chef und der
chefin
ich möchte jetzt gehen oder wie hier
schlecht machen weil beim schöpfer der
chef in einem besseren licht nachdenken
möchte
[Musik]
ja da hat der ganze ali geht es ist eine
story wieder zugemacht
auch das kann man halt auch historische
ereignisse kann man eine moral
psychologischen damit ihren ist eben
immer so das historische ereignisse
wiederum spezialfälle darstellt wenn man
hier lebender nicht mehr
aber es sollen sich jeder so bestand
nyse fusioniert die größere coface und
ist als
antworten auf einen täter zukommen und
das tv-publikum als akteure umfassen
können wir gruppen eine intensitäten zu
sprechen also kann die komplizierten
produzieren verfolgen sicherlich ist
scheint doch immer hier in analogie
das ist ein zusätzliches problem was uns
sich gestellt aber natürlich kann man
historische ereignisse und phänomene
geben brauchen unter diesen
gesichtspunkten sehen
aber es wird schwieriger das wird viel
schwieriger das wasser zu machen ja
genau als wir haben jetzt ein paar
lieder neid missgunst eifersucht
selbstprofilierung es ist sogar möglich
das opfer soll vielmehr die serie und
damit sukzessive in eine deprimierende
unterlegene und ohnmächtige position
gebracht
schauen sie jetzt sagen sie des box muss
daher dürfte immer prächtig
die der nadelstiche präferieren und von
also extrem gemeinheit absehen mitnehmen
sich aussichten beteiligter dritter
vermutlich selbst angreifbar macht und
als selbsttäuschung auch täuschen sich
selbst wenn norbert täuschung des
momentes auch in mobilen wir dürfen das
moment als mobbing darstellen sondern
dass sachen werden sich darüber
beschwert ich werde die opferzahl was
das bildest du dir nur ein paar minuten
belegte stimmt doch genau genommen kann
du benimmst dich hier sowieso in dieser
art mit dem mann aus sicht und mit einer
der täter vermutlich selbst angreifen
sich machen würde hier klingen zugleich
auch schon eine unmoralische art von
mobbing an
geht man auch von racheakten kennen
robert ist ein revierverhalten oder
besser ein verhaltensmuster das mit sehr
unterschiedlichen einzeltaten
einhergehenden ahv langzeitfolgen des
mobbings gar keine handlung
sagt es einfach halten diese
unterscheidung hatten wir ja also wir
haben das ja auch das halten derzeit
sehr verschieden sein verhalten er würde
jetzt sagen mobbing ist hier ein
verhalten mich eine andere
ich bin mir nicht sicher aber es sagt
jedenfalls glauben dass hier für
unterschiedliche ein zitat unter den
taten sind zum beispiel beleidigungen
die mutigen verleumdungen programme zu
verbreiten erst wenn genügend solche 1
getan zusammen kommen und für den
betroffenen
psychoterror staaten mit ein fall von
pink vor sind es nämlich wollten es ein
[Musik]
er sagt einen nutzer ich finde ventil
thematik beim mobbing moraltheologe
stören aber durchaus interessanten
transportiere aus einer art zählt mein
eigenes
auch andere wenn das so fisch sehr
spannend jahre ist sicherlich das war
das problem mit der psychologischen
interpretation
wenn man eine solche form des
moralischen psychologisch interpretiert
ist es durchaus ein ansatzpunkt aber
muss neben immer noch philosophische
kategorien mit ins spiel nehmen und die
philosophischen katalin kategorien
betreffen immer im tief die handlungen
internationalität selbst zu löschen als
er muss dann das psychologische noch
weiter mit philosophischen kommen
beschreiben ich will damit nicht sagen
dass man nicht die psychologische
begriffe benutzen darf und muss er noch
tiefer passen eben letztendlich muss man
leben zurückführen auf uns wird freiheit
das scheint mit der konz sein wenn man
das nicht macht nicht diese ganzen
moralischen dingen auf unsere freiheit
geführt dann mussten uns ja auch unsere
natur zurückführen dann muss man sie auf
die evolutionsbiologie zu führen das
machen die man aber viele psychologen
konnten dann können wir gleich sein
müssen
notieren also das ist glaube ich der
unterschied wenn ihr psychologisches
sind immer vor dem hintergrund zu
befreien
dann wird daraus eine philosophische
sagen wie schön der tierwelt mobbing
auch beim menschen zunächst in drei
konformen auf der ersten variante rotten
sich die gänse gegen ein als gefährlich
eingestuften schauen funktion zusammen
lebt sie allein unterlegen während der
zwei bei der defa lassen um einen mühsam
konnten aus dem bereich her dessen
ebenbürtigkeit bringen gefährlich werden
kann und im dritten fall vergreifen sich
gewinnen fächert direkt ansprechen und
sich an der mieterbund zu laden
es ist vielleicht nicht schlecht dass
wir mal ein bisschen sieht in einer
bestimmten relation gesehen werden zum
thema ist so ein aber das opfer ist
etwas gefährlicher zu der höhe
aufgefasst dieser schlaue fuchs
das heißt es die bedrohung oder das
immer so die das ärgernis das ärgernis
der anlass des ärgernisses für das kann
eben aus verschiedenen einstufiges
einstufung meinung
entstehen das opfer kann ebenfalls etwas
höheres gefährlich ansehen wir ein neuer
mitarbeiter konto der ist besser dies
besser als wir die markus konkurrenz was
sagt jetzt die chefin die wird sie am
erste befördern und hiergegen keine
gehaltserhöhung ist eine gefahr in strom
dann kann weshalb jemand der so auf der
gleichen ebene angesiedelt wird und dann
gibt es halt jemanden den man auf den
nur herabblickt der aber auch irgendwie
als solches provozieren kann hier eine
neue anwendung es gibt auch menschen die
mobbing regelrecht heraus provozieren so
dass es für die vermeintlich manager
wieder als eine art erfahren haben wir
verhalten gesehen werden kann muss das
nicht immer aufpassen
das ist es schwieriger punkt also
grundsätzlich würde ich sagen wenn
jemand sagt ich werde dem mond müssen
wir ihnen das nicht ernst
das system verfügt
grundsätzlich muss man geben den ernst
nehmen würde ich sagen
oder wie auch von sich aus sagt
gemeinden zu gehören das muss man ernst
aber es gibt natürlich auch dem fall das
muss man auch sehen wo man sich selbst
zum opfer stilisiert wo man es
eigentlich gar nicht ist
es wird viel komplizierter das heißt
dass man selbst auch unmoralisch sein
kann bestimmen und die anderen ist eben
auch das ist natürlich höchst
problematisch
also diese technologischen fragen nach
der erkenntnis nach dem feststellung von
moment ist ganz schwierig und zwar
deswegen weil mehr wichtig ob wir das
immer immer verdeckt wird es nicht offen
es ist also ganz schwierig das von hier
aus zu betrachten gibt es im
arbeitsrecht und so weiter als ich denke
um objektive meiden muss man
alternativen ganz konkret mich einfach
wieder gestaltet ist man muss der tür
man muss viele türen letztendlich ein
bauer in den raum dass man sich nicht zu
sehr auf die pelle rückt und das wird
möglichkeit ich glaube dass mit der
architektonischen designmäßig gestalt
eines arbeitsplatzes allein schon viele
anhalt durch die räumliche ordnung kann
als es der raum den wir immer
berücksichtigt ist jetzt noch ein
bisschen weiter darüber hinaus und
sozialpsychologische berufswelt
forschung auch noch ein viertes
feindseliges als muster beobachten von
dem jedoch umstritten ist ob es als
mobil bezahlt werden sind gemeint ist ob
es gemeint ist für so genannte post
verdient aggressionen nicht von
kolleginnen und kollegen stark sind
direkt von oben kommen zb für
vorarbeiten abteilungsleiter im geschäft
dabei
unter ausnutzung des vorhandenen hoch
macht und gleichgewichtssinn gesetze im
kündigungsschutz der post zu umgehen
dass sie nie gehört haben sich in boston
es gibt sicherlich brauchen es gibt ganz
interessante konstellation dass ich dann
die chefin mit dem kollegen verbündet
gegen jemanden vielleicht gegen forst
unser wald ganz verschiedene
konstellationen und hierbei
berücksichtigt
einst leiter der bereits erwähnte
arbeitspsychologin hat im anschluss an
sein empirischen versuch eine typologie
spezifischer mobil akte vorgestellt die
in fünf gruppen einteilten das ist bei
uns wieder so viele und philosophen auch
relevant diese klassifikation in der die
erste gruppe gehören versuche die
kommunikative freiheit wieder opfer
einzustechen
die gemobbte person kommt in gemeinsamen
gesprächen nicht mehr sofort wurde sie
mit ständig unterbrochen
man bestimmt 13 schneider
das hatten wir schon oder geht wenn sie
reden allerdings noch eins was gibt es
noch die luftmassen schweizer einen
blick wohin musste begehen
für diskriminierende tusche blieb kennen
sie diese klingen wie nach außen
vertreten kennen sie ihr dass wir die
der blick nachdem der genervten blick
nach oben und ständig dinge der telefone
aber niemanden ist in der zweiten gruppe
sind verhaltensmuster versammelt eine
wachsende isolation der opfer anderen
mann redet schließlich gar nicht mehr
mit ihnen behandelt sie die luft
schaut durch sie hindurch und
weidetieren lässt sie
in der werkskantine allein am tisch
sitzen oder verlegen ihren arbeitsplatz
in ein staubiges keller auf oder direkt
zur toilette in die dritte gruppe
gehören gezielte angriffe auf das
soziale ansehen der person wird
unbedingt gestichelt und verkauft 1
beneidet und gebet an kommentierte ihre
stimme ihren gesten macht sich über
ihren ganz lustig man spricht hinter
ihrem rücken streut gerüchte um von
neuen einzige ziel gesehen ist es kein
fachwissenschaften jetzt bewusst sehen
uns hier ein populärwissenschaft und dem
ort aber nichtsdestotrotz ist ein gutes
buch
in der vierten kurve finden sich solche
maßnahmen mit dem man unmittelbare
arbeitsleistung der betroffene person zu
sabotieren versucht man entwindet mir
wichtig unterlagen oder enthält er
wichtige informationen vor dass wenn ich
mich die dieses ausschließen aus dem
informations kontext aus den augen aus
wissen was frauen ausgrenzen und über
direkte und klare sieger unsere gern
erniedrigende aufgaben sitzt sie massiv
unter zeitungen und übt dort sogleich
auf empfehlungen
der weiße kritik dass aufpassen dass man
dem kritisiert und das darf
zu fünft und der liebe schließlich sei
man handfest über die für sexuelle
belästigung bedingt sind in form
sachbeschädigung körpers
sie kennen alle den zerstochene
autoreifen
das ist so latent aggressive signale die
gar nicht existieren der person als auch
die der körper der besten ab 10 sind auf
ihrem kontext als es der metapher oder
so eine übertragung also dieser
verstorbene autoreifen das übertrage mal
und ich nenne es ist so
da kannst du denn das ganze also hier
habe das land die eskalationsstufen
stufe und das ist uns auch wieder die
philosophie stelle man dass wir
untersuchen werden liefern können wie es
weiter heißt form das unmoralisch
differenzieren
eskalationsstufe im natürlich mode
minuten der strategien die jeweils
intakt
ich glaube dass nehmen auch jetzt kommen
noch immer fleißig endspiel
sobald es die richtige bald auftreten
wird sie schnell einreichen produktives
weil eben das arbeitszimmer ausüben
die vom opfer als bekämpft und
entmutigend das ist jetzt noch
perspektiven erlebnisse kann zum plan
ist errichtete hindernisse oder wohnt
heute in belasten die nur ein einziges
ihrer form in das leben stehe oder eben
sauer zu sein gegen uns dann verstellt
diesen nebeneffekt wenn man gemobbte
besser und vorletzten unklaren darüber
lässt man sie eigentlich macht so dass
es sich den kopf darüber zerbrechen mit
taxi falsch gemacht haben schauen sie
das jetzt opferperspektive aber noch
nicht gefunden
selbst verriet getäuscht warum es zum
vierzehnten wissen ja wenn man den grund
etwas weißenfels eine viel leichter das
leid anzeigen
aber wenn man den kontakt nicht mal
reist dann wird das noch viel viel
schlimmer als das ist auch noch nicht
gehoben das sind wir auch
und dass das bauprojekt ihr film das
ganze jahr betrachtet nicht nur aus der
täter damit soll setzt von mobbing
erstmal
genug sein ich möchte jetzt nutze
diskriminierung übergeben
die folien können sie alle hier
unternimmt an dem video mit sich
die habe ich hier unten einen verleger
diskriminierung für diskriminierte jedem
deshalb war das ist die 63
wir leben das opfer diskreditiert mein
hobby das beklemmend und eine grundlose
ich kite und wahrheit wenig interessen
und werte werden durch das gremium
verletzt
das dem lateinischen entlehnt wurde es
wieder aus dem wollmarkt es erst den
heimischen oder mama erstmal zurück
machen wir mal ab unabhängig von von
jetzt vom polo finden sie formen im
alltag für diskriminierung hatte mal
konkret beispiel für diskriminierung
frage ist es letztlich
muss es dieses mal
zunächst hatte
mainz jetzt die gruppe betrieben jahr
einstecken müssen nicht also ich denen
die diskriminierungen sache es auf den
freund mein eigentlich nur
unterschreiben aber unterscheiden auf
eine weise die nicht gerechtfertigt ist
also disziplinen oder ja das display ist
eigentlich nur das porträt auf
unterhaltung der beschreibung und
diskriminiert plätzen in form der
unterscheidung die aber nicht
moralischen anderen ist ich entscheide
etwas wirklich geheim der eine person
aufgrund eines in der schweiz erstmals
das aber nicht
die scheiben rechtecke und das genau
individuum aufgrund von besonderen
individuell gestalten die dann zum
anlassen 100 diskriminierung
ich kann voll gut ganz neue
eigenschaften die nominierung
auszeichnen investiert wird und zwar des
und zwar insofern als diese eigenschaft
finde ich vielleicht nicht aufweisen
dass die keinen grund für die für die
unterscheidung darstellung dass es nicht
die basis sein sollte auf berge
unterscheidung getroffen
wenn man unterscheiden kann man genau
die frage jetzt nur darf diese dieses
unterscheidungsmerkmal ein wirklich der
anlass oder die motivation für diese
unterscheidungen zeit niemand geht es um
die kriterien aber haben sie
ja zum beispiel hat oder
genau hautfarbe oder sexuelle
ausrichtung uns aber diese forderung
kann man sich die ganze breite der jetzt
endlich auf grund von ca
einerseits wenn man das sagt eine
frauendomäne werden denn dann geht das
natürlich nicht auf individuelle
eigenschaften zu rechner
das könne man kann nur weil man eine
frau ist was ja nichts individuelles
ziel ist eine biologische kategorie
diskriminiert werden kann man kann aber
eben auch aufgrund von ganz
individuellen diskriminiert wird aber
häufig glaube da haben sie recht ist es
diskriminierende merkmal etwas was ein
zu einer gruppe zugehörig bekenntnis
aber ich glaube es muss nicht nur mit
einer gruppen möglichkeit als ich denke
wir brauchen gar nicht geben das ist
sehr präsent
diese möglichen diskriminierung gründe
daraufhin sackte ziert das dem
lateinischen linke wehrt diskriminieren
beteuert er schlicht unterscheiden wer
sich als und beklagt dass menschen
diskriminiert werden würden sich fragen
lassen müssen was ist so schlimm daran
unterschied zwischen menschen zu machen
die einheit thomas oder stephanie die
anderen vater oder meine hände fielen
anderem apple manche sind große andré
kleiner die ein bogen die anderen alle
zb 2g alters ist das auto als es gibt
jedes merkmal keine beziehung anders
einer diskriminierung von manchen denkt
das ist ein junger halt für die
verheiratung tätig also zum beispiel
familien mit kindern können
diskriminiert werden wenn die kinder bis
hin zu laut sind kriegen sie keine
mietwohnung von einer hübschen kanal
oder besonders begehrt
genauso können wiederum kinderlose paare
diskriminiert werden vielleicht oder
sich krieges geführt von steuerlichen
richten und das steuerrecht für diesen
sie kommen aus afrika amerika asien
austragen oder buddhisten christen
müssen im nächsten mai wissen und viele
der gar nichts auch kurz menschen sind
verschieden
das sind jetzt verschiedenheit die
menschen in gruppen das war ja in der
regel schon habe ich denke auch dass
diskriminierung aufgrund von einer ganz
individuellen eigenschaften zb über die
stimmen jemandem gefällt meine stimme
oder jemandem gefällt irgendwie der
direkten gesprächen der natürlich auch
wieder hier unsere gruppen gehörig kite
hinweis aber es kann auch sein dass sie
dieser direkt von dieser person und dann
ist es auch ein möglicher
diskriminierung hatte ich glaube nicht
dass er das immer auf der gruppen
doch es gab eine zeit in der man eben
nicht ganz so welt auch war der
pluralismus in szene mit einer bewährten
bernd anschaffen der moderne und der
globalisierung früher in traditionellen
gesellschaften eigene menschen für ihr
dazu die gemeinschaft auf homogenität zu
kochen und sich nach dem großen hin nach
101 füße abzuschaffen
das fremde macht ihm angst wort anlass
zu vorurteilen es weckte aggressionen
bis hin zu offenen hass und natürlich
gibt es auch heute noch viele menschen
die entsprechende form der dinge und
sich mit dem realismus schwerte hat
standort auf dem schützenswerten ein und
spricht und gerne
weiter und ihr seht als der herr
pollmann der orientierung der stadt
stellung
was mir jetzt hier kann das der des
momentes verwendet das scheint mir zu
sein dass fremde das andere dass es auch
so eine operation die viele wale
stranden unmoralischen handlungen zu
grunde liegt
als abgrenzung vertrauen und auch im
mobbing glaube ich bekannt diese
unterscheidung des fremden sonst ein
wichtiges grund motto seid also wir als
eingeschworene gruppe und deren tiere zu
finden was er mir zu ende heißt eben der
andere glauben wahrscheinlich
bewährteste andere ist auch noch eine
typische 19
kanton ist in obernburg wenige boxer am
[Musik]
der andere der fremde dieses klar auch
so eine grund kategorie die sie
motivieren kann ja jetzt wird's hier
sehr klar wer steht laut nissen
entspringen in der soziologie die sich
für gesellschaftliche explosions
erfahrungen zuständig weiß spricht man
immer mit einem stigma das ist ein
wichtiges signal wenn man auf ein
normales und deshalb besonders
hervorstechen des persönlichkeitsmerkmal
schauen das kann auch eine individuelle
person betreffen einen sozialen marke
hinweisen will
ursprünglich waren es die rechte brand
und wunsch gerade das heißt körperlichen
verzierung und welches team die wir
schon von weitem ein wie auch immer
geartetes
erkennen ließen und die man heute in
form von tätowierungen oder piercings
die ihren trägern etwas verruchtes und
ein anständiges nach also kennen sie in
der bibel
mobile eine geschichte ganz zu beginn
die auch diese stigmatisierung enthält
kain und abel an dieses keims war das
ist auch eine art von stigmatisierung
könnte man sagen die hier aber natürlich
im baikal noch nicht unmoralisch
geblendet war weil der kein ja dadurch
gestützt realisation dass er dieses
zeichen trägt weil er als ein guter
getötet hat damit er nicht selbst
getötet wird hat er diese zeichen
bekommen ich glaube da rauskommen
das ist so eine form der stigmatisierung
und zentrierung für die total sprache
wenn sie in buchform ein buch theorien
des bösen ein lesen was ihn auch zu geld
machen kann
da habe ich ein eigenes kapitel über
tätowierungen also bei groß und kennen
sie diesen sehr diesen typen
ein italienischer club der 100 und damit
habe ich sehr gefasst und er hat eine
these vertreten aber damals an diesen
tagen sollte das also verbrecher der
übermäßig häufig tätowiert der reise
selbst stigmatisiert als es eine
interessante these aber natürlich nicht
halten können sie mal ein sieg ist also
wichtig hier diskriminierung hat auch
immer mit stigmatisierung zu tun
das heißt es geht um ein zeit ins system
also bezahlt oder semiotik und hier
werden die menschen zeichnet sich die
aktiven als kulturwissenschaftler haben
die moralität haben immer was mit
brandmarkung zu tun
abgrenzen zeit mit kommunikationsform
mit bezeichnungen und endzeiten
und das scheint mir auch eine form der
city zu sein natürlich auch eine form
der pragmatik wie wir eben mit sprache
etwas tun aber da sind wir in mir
scheint in der mitte wieder so werden
mittlerweile hätten diese körper schon
fast zum mehr zufrieden gehört würde
unserer zeit besonders feucht
abnormitäten stigmatisieren die
inzwischen menschen verkehrs geführt von
regen oder gar anstrengend wäre zb
schwere krankheiten wie depressionen
oder körperlich einstellungen wie
behinderten aber auch ein langes
vorstrafenregister eine schwere kindheit
sozial stieg jahr sogar armut und
arbeitslosigkeit und können
stigmatisierend stigmatisierung aber
zusammengefasst ist eine diskriminierung
oder eine spezifische behandlung in der
regel eine abwehrende landung
aufgrund von zahlreichen aufgrund von
zeichnungen die aber als zeichen und
nichts schlechtes bedeuten es geht also
immer mehr an bedeutung
und hier geht es um bedeutungs zuschauer
von zeichen die diese bedeutung nicht
recht härter als nur weil ich ein tattoo
habe muss nämlich die verbrecher sein
das heißt und das hatte neben viele
kriminologen freund sind der produktion
gesehen haben zeichnen zeichen bedeuten
wir haben darauf geschossen
wir zeichnen als der präsentationen
genommen was fixes was ich drängte führt
vielleicht auch für eine substanz der
geborenen verbrecher jazz und enorm groß
und hat dieses gutgeschrieben nur
modelle krank also der geborenen
verbrecher die verbrecher menschen also
es gibt menschen die zum verbrecher dem
wohnsitz und diese verbrecher die
integrieren sich häufig und
dementsprechend auch eine ganz besondere
erfahrung und die haben sogar eine ganz
besondere handschrift so weit gehen dass
der verbrecher anschrift analysiert und
die die verwenden besondere metaphern
und sie haben sogar einen ganz
besonderen als er hat das gemacht haben
eine gange folge dass die fußabdrücke
die so unglücklich die errechnete
aufbrechen
das ist natürlich aus dem geist des
positivismus erwachsene der positivismus
heißt und versuche immer mehr auf grund
von häusern zeichnungen rückschlüsse
ziehen
positiv im gegeben und das ist das ganz
späte 19
jahrhundert sehr positivistische
eingestellt was anhand des problems den
positivismus der verlust matti sierung
weil er einfach nur das zeichen möchte
und vom zeichen direkt auf die
bedeutungslos ist natürlich ein
kurzschluss jeder der anträgen überhaupt
mit ist dann verbrecher und ich war
jetzt über pfingsten
neben leipzig gewesen durch zufall ist
und da waren ganz für den gott nix also
die coffee team ohne einen 30.000 im
land sind und dann hörte ich eine frau
erzählen
das sei als auch die friedlichste
veranstaltung sind im jahr stattfindet
da sei gar keine polizei obwohl wir
durch diese grafik story aus furcht
einflößen aus dem kann mit ihrem fördern
und in ihren straßen gewinn damit auch
das wäre unter umständen ein fehlschluss
vom die zeichen auf die bedeutung wir
müssen immer betrieben inzwischen
zeichnen und der bedeutung die wir diese
zeit
ich glaube dass das wichtig ist jetzt
ein punkt könnte aber auch schon weit
weniger gravierende unterschiede anreise
zu diskriminierungen die betrachten wie
ein geradezu ergebnis beispiel aus dem
arbeits und ein autohaus luft ein
verkäufer und der chef des hauses
überlegen wegen bewährung wie zb die
bäder zu einem gespräch bitten säuren
erste gesetz zwar ausreichend erfahrung
ist er bereits zu alt für das flotte an
1000 alles eine zweite bewerbung wird
schon deshalb nicht eingeladen weil sie
das falsche geschlecht oder auch die
falsche gesichtsfarbe hat der dritte
bewerber der mann bei der arbeit und
zwar aus religiösen klare einfache
häuser unübliches kleidungsstücken zu
lassen
ein vierter kandidat enthält ist keine
einladung weil der chef des bauhaus nach
genauer betrachtung des bewerbungsfotos
zu der auffassung gelangt dass ist dass
er wie er sagt es mit einer schule
müssten wir sind jetzt alles wie sie
sehen nur zeichen also kleidung fotos
waren die beiden dessen zeichen gegen
eine bestimmte bedeutung zugesprochen
die arbeit gar nicht verwirrt wird
hinter dem nun schon gar nicht an jetzt
ist es raus
das gilt etwa für autos gekauft als jede
dieser eigenschaften zugesprochen wird
ist als solche überhaupt nicht im
widerspruch stehen zu diesem zweck des
unterhauses
dabei wollen wir erstmal belassen die
szene bekommen es in einem komplexen
kommunikationsmodell es gibt auch
grenzen abschotten zu sprechen von
bedeutung verzeichnen ich glaube das ist
auch nicht gewaschen bekommen einen
wechsel sitzung noch einmal kurz zurück
auf diskriminierung ein sehr spannendes
und präsentes thema und werden uns dann
den augen der interessantesten
phänomenen von obwohl allen formen zu
finden nämlich dem lesen erst und zwar
deswegen weil ich glaube dass hier die
moral selbst zum anlass der heutigen
kann also das ist mit die größte
intellektuell ist in leistung die im
indianischen vollzogen
deswegen hat es etwas zu sagen und dem
moralismus schaffen
die basis sein für fanatismus und
terrorismus den wir ja immer
die dann wünsche ihnen trotz dieser sehr
unerfreulich und problematische form des
moralischen noch eine schöne und gute
woche und bis zur nächsten sitzung